great it looks like we are live hello so
I'm so happy you're joining us for this
live stream where we are going to talk
about the AI act so about the European
Union's plans to regulate artificial
intelligence
I am letita I'm a researcher in Ai and
I'm also running the AI Coffee Break
YouTube channel where I explain latest
research in AI so I am aware that AI can
create many benefits such as better
Healthcare more efficient manufacturing
and so on the list can grow much longer
than this but at the same time as we
rely more and more onto AI systems it
can pose potential risks so I was very
excited when I saw that the very
important step that you is taking now
when it comes to AI the European
Parliament plans to regulate artificial
intelligence with the intention to
ensure that this technology helps us for
the better and keeps us safe from the
worse so I thank the European Parliament
for the opportunity to be here today
because what is a better chance to learn
more about the AI act other than from
the parliament members in charge of the
AI act Mr Brando benifee and Mr Ivan
dragosh tudorake I'm so excited about
this so Mr benefay and Mr tudorake thank
you for speaking with me today and maybe
we can start slowly to get everybody on
the same page can you tell us crisply in
a nutshell what are the main points of
the AI act and what does it mean that it
is a risk-based regulation
well I maybe I can start
um thank you for this opportunity well
the AI Act is uh uh the first ever uh
regulation of this kind in the world in
fact we have similar uh
ideas all over the world on risk
reduction that is the core of this
regulation but this is the first time we
put it in a legislation it's not a
voluntary code it's not a recommendation
it's law that can be enforced that can
defend the interests and the rights of
citizens in a in a higher level for sure
the core of this legislation the idea
behind it is the fact that we should
have a
human-centered AI developed in Europe
that we should defend our values our
model and also build a dialogue with the
rest of the world around how we can make
AI compatible with democracy supportive
of
emancipation of of people of giving more
opportunities and not
instead create more fractures or fuel
disinformation or
create a control State we have been
working on that and we built a
risk-based approach that
identifies a high risk AI use cases that
needs to be more regulated that needs to
be checked on data used to train it the
human oversight the technical
requirements that are there to mitigate
and reduce risks for people for their
health their safety their fundamental
rights and we also identify the uses
that we think should be outrightly
banned like
the use of biometric identification in
public spaces on real time to avoid by
Banning it the risk of mass surveillance
and we also ban the predictive policing
social scoring emotion recognition for
students workers because we think that
in these cases there is no added value
and more risks than benefits so we we
built this architecture and this I would
say are from my side the the gist of how
the AI Act is is organized and how it it
is defined
thank you very much I think it is a
great idea to go and say yeah let's ban
specific use cases and let's regulate
specific use cases rather than saying uh
let's stop oai that is doing computer
vision so the kind of AI that processes
images or video or let's uh ban language
models so all of the AI that processes
natural language and it's right to
identify this um these cases where where
you want it to be banned in cases where
you want just to have a look over it in
some cases that are just fine and should
just be going on like they do but I'm
very curious what exactly falls under
the category of AI like when does
something when does a face recognition
system come into this category of AI and
when is it regulated
well we have a definition of AI and I
think that is a starting point and it
hasn't been easy in the negotiations in
Parliament to to find common ground on
how to define AI how to differentiate AI
from General software because there is
already quite a broad range a very
complex software out there but which is
not AI and we want it to be very clear
and very very sharp in the way we Define
ai so that again we're not unnecessarily
cover software that should not be
covered by the text so AI in in the view
of of the parliament but we're also
consistent with what the council has
adopted as more or less
still some nuances to be defined and to
be negotiated but more or less we're on
the same page which is to recognize the
fact that an AI has to work with a
certain degree of autonomy
and in the content that it generates it
has to be able to influence or capable
of influencing either virtual or
physical environments and that is the
key element that differentiates AI from
other type of software so whether we
look at applications that are in the
prohibition list to applications that
are in in high risk we have to first
make sure and differentiate and make
sure that it is indeed Ai and that it
comes indeed under the scope of the
regulation before we determine whether
it is one of those applications that
would be prohibited or not and the same
stands true for for biometric
identification
and do you think that if a company
releases a technology do you need to
look inside into let's say the code or
its infrastructure and its data to
decide whether it's AI or not or or can
you just uh know that something falls
under the AI regulation by seeing how it
works like measuring this autonomy part
because otherwise you would need
companies to decrease close their
technology and maybe they can or if they
hide it they just say yeah it's an if
else program it's not a deep neural
network well we are working on the
Assumption of self-assessment this is
the underlying
rule that we have introduced in the text
so companies will self-assess and they
will self-assess on the basis of the
definitions that are in the text and the
criteria that are in the text and it is
then if their determination is that they
are in the category of high risk then
there are obligations that have to do
with transparency and indeed with
explainability which means that they
will have to explain what kind of data
they use to train the algorithm what
kind of instructions did they give to
the to the algorithm so on and so forth
we don't ask them to disclose the code
itself because that might even be
protected by law but we're asking them
to give those technical elements and to
describe the functionalities of the
system that would allow people to
ultimately do what to ultimately trust
the system because all of these
obligations that the law introduces are
meant to introduce trust so that we as
consumers we as end users for these
systems have the confidence that when
interacting with these AI algorithms our
rights are not uh are not affected so
that's ultimately the philosophy that
the that the law follows
okay great
ER companies but also I'm I was
wondering whether there will be some
technical experts that keep track of the
development and the uh and propose
adjustments for example to the law if
needed and will there be an office that
would be
um where one could report possible
infringements if let's say a company
doesn't do self-assessment in the way
they should do it
yes for sure uh the issue of flexibility
of this legislation has always been at
the core of our attention as you
mentioned earlier the fact that we focus
on use cases uh it's important rather
than just on the technology itself
because this will make this legislation
more durable and less at risk of
obsolescence but at the same time we
have foreseen various degrees of
facilitation for the modification of the
areas that are under the um high risk
classification
the
Articles themselves so we we will need
to negotiate still with the member
states on the exact technical
Arrangements but I think we share the
idea that we need some flexibility in
the way we can update and modify the
legislation more quickly so to adapt to
further changes
but also
we we can say that we are working all
the time with the technical
experts with stakeholders from Academia
from the businesses and we also foresee
for the AI office we call it that's the
evolution of the AI board that was
foreseen by the European commission to
engage with these experts and do its its
part in coordinating the work of the
national supervisory authorities this
aspect on which
I have to say also especially colleague
Tudor Racha worked a lot in the in the
drafting that we have made of the
governance and enforcement is crucial
because if we do not uh get it right so
that we have a good combination of a
European coordination and execution when
necessary and the national authorities
to talk with each other coordinate so
that we can identify infringements we
can identify when the rule the rules are
not respected and people can be damaged
they can be exposed to a risk then if we
don't do this correctly then the law
stays only as a paper
um instead as we give as we give
confidence to the developers that they
do self-assessment at the same time it's
important that we have our ways to check
uh if everything is is right and that
the institutions can do their part so
that the law is actually applied if I
might at any one one point on this
because you use the word expert and I
think this is one of the fundamental
points in securing indeed the successful
implementation of the law because it
will matter a lot whether the national
authorities will manage to find the
right experts underlying the word
experts to be able to interact properly
with the companies that will be
developing these algorithms that will be
knocking at the door of the national
regulator to ask questions to interact
with them maybe in the sandbox because
we have also provided in the law for the
possibility of sandboxes so again the
capacity of national authorities to
secure these experts to secure the
expertise and populate the future
National authorities with these experts
is is key is fundamental for how the law
will be implemented
okay that's great to hear and I hope
that will work out and that the national
committees will be formed from experts
um I I have another question related to
um what um regulation applies to because
it's kind of clear in everybody's mind
that um that if there's a huge company
that wants to deliver its services on EU
territory then it has to comply to the
AI act but does it even go to the level
of a person so let's suppose I want to
make an Instagram post uh of um of
something and I want to generate a an
image from with you know one of the
latest neural networks and um does it
even apply to me there that I have to um
I have to specify that um
that it is AI generated because if it
doesn't apply to me then why should it
apply to let's say people who try to
manipulate elections by doing Instagram
posts or even I mean one can escalate
this in a very um bad way so what is at
which does it apply it uh individual
level and does it mean that uh everybody
needs to highlight now that it generated
something with AI
I think the the key starting point to
understand how the law functions and
it's important to know that this is what
it has started at least at the beginning
as a as a product safety regulation
which fundamentally means what that if
you go on the market if you Market the
product then the rules apply to you
and there so if you put something on the
market
and as an individual using a system you
are not in that logic
but whether you are an individual that
develops big or small an algorithm that
has the potential of bringing about
risks to someone and falls on the scope
of the legislation then yes that the law
will apply to you as well whether you
are small or big so the size of the
company whether one single person or a
company like one of the big five it
doesn't matter what matters is again
whether the product or the service
driven by AI that you put on the market
and that's the starting point
falls into one of the risks on one of
the risk categories that the legislation
includes
but then maybe a stupid question now I
can also add one thing on this uh just
to as you mentioned the creation of a
post I can imagine Maybe by helping
yourself with a generative AI uh system
I I can say that the parliament compared
to the original text compared to also
the work of the governments has been
more advanced in tackling in its version
of the text that now we need to be
confronted with the with the version of
the of the governments to have a final
text has been more advanced more open
and and clear on tackling the issue of
the generative AI so again this goes
back to those that developed the the
systems rather than you that are using
it but we have been
putting some clear obligations
especially on we can say a form of
enhanced transparency because we want to
make the content generated by a
generative AI systems to be identifiable
as such as a non-human generated content
we want to ask the developers to put all
the effort to reduce the risks of
creation of illegal content to also make
the Deep fakes identifiable Because deep
fakes risk to be the new frontier of a
mass disinformation and this will
interact also with another important
piece of legislation the Digital
Services act that is entering into force
and that governs what circulates in the
in the online platforms and finally the
copyright
protection because we have the
legislation on copyright that is
existing already at EU and National
level we do not change it but we want to
protect the rights the existing rights
of the authors and creatives that are
being now in in a difficult in a week's
position in front of systems that just
digest all materials and use them for
training and then they they produce also
works of of art if we can say but they
are trained with materials that are not
their own so we need to find a balance
on that we need to make this transparent
so that we can also see where there is
the need for a remuneration or
compensation
yeah I guess my confusion starts because
I'm also a researcher and for me it's
kind of unclear when is a research
product already just research and look
this is what I've done and I publish a
paper and when is my code already a
product because I could just say look
I'm open AI I just released this thing
called Chachi PT and you can use it and
play with it
um does this mean that uh it's uh if if
I say it's research is it already a
product or when does it really become a
product do I have to request money for
it exactly that's a that's a very
important point because we have two
exceptions two exemptions that we
introduce in the law the first exemption
is for r d
so in our view research and development
should be Exempted from the scope of the
law because again it is not yet
something that is put on the market and
yes put on the market
to uh to gain an income to to to for for
commercial gain let's say and then we
also have an exemption when it comes to
open AI uh sorry not open AI to open
source AI so open source AI is Exempted
from the scope of the regulation unless
it is embedded in high risk applications
so high risk and the element of risk
remains Central in the way the law
applies and in the logic of the of the
law so even if you are open source but
if you are in a high risk area then you
will have to comply but otherwise again
open source is Exempted just like r d is
great thanks a lot
and see the time is pressing so I have
one final
timeline
of the adoption of the AI act like when
do we have to think that the the new AI
act will most likely become applicable
well we are working a lot to conclude
that these negotiations uh in a short
time because the AI Act is uh is needed
we want it to become law soon so we are
hoping to conclude by the end of the
year these negotiations to make it a
final approval of this law at the
beginning of next year then we have uh
now foreseen two years time before it
becomes uh and it enters into Force so
uh for for now it would be that it
becomes fully applicable a beginning of
2026 with this timeline however we will
for sure talk about possible shortening
partial shortening of this timing
because it might look a bit too long
maybe we can adapt it and in any case
even if we don't change it there are
voluntary compliance initiatives going
on especially we can mention the AI I
packed that is being built to from the
commission side to make the AI act
being complied with voluntarily by
businesses and public authorities before
it's entering to force this would be
especially important for example if we
look at one topic that often comes up
the European election since 2024.
um when will the AI act be applicable to
what will be
happening around the elections no
because it will not be entered into
Force but it could be applied
voluntarily with the AI pact and also
there is also an international level
initiative the AI code of conduit on
generative AI that is the idea to at
least on generative AI have some basic
common rules at a larger International
level in the G7 context or even further
and this is also an initiative from the
commission science that we we support
yeah and I guess that a lot of companies
have quite some incentive to become
future proof by already starting to uh
comply to this so yeah it's great so
thanks a lot uh Mr tudoraken Mr benefay
thanks for being with us today and a big
thank you also to our viewers for tuning
in and I'm really glad to have
participated in this informative
discussion and I guess we are all
curious to see how this will develop and
shape Society in the future and I'm
hopeful that this will pan out
successfully so thanks a lot thank you
thank you